de tout temps des agriculteurs ont tiré
leurs revenus de la vente de produits
agricoles les céréales des œufs du lait
de la viande et pour la première fois
dans l'histoire une nouvelle source de
revenus potentiels apparaît à la ferme
posée de bons gestes pour
l'environnement peut désormais être
payant grâce au marché du carbone
[Musique]
c'est une journée bien occupée à la
ferme du producteur laitier Guillaume
faucher pendant qu'il multiplie les
passages au champ et garde un œil sur sa
première Coupe de foin
ailleurs sur sa terre une petite équipe
fait son entrée au chant car un autre
chantier se prépare le long de deux
cours d'eau dont la rivière Chaudière
800 arbres et plus de 300 arbustes
prendront racines les essences sont
variés des conifères des feuillus des
arbustes fruitiers et on ne laissera pas
le sol à nu ces graines se met à la
volée deviendront des fleurs qui
nourriront les pollinisateurs
de façon volontaire donc on a deux
rangées d'arbres supplémentaires qui
excèdent la réglementation une captation
de carbone en fait puis on vient
augmenter la bonne riveraine pour
protéger un petit peu plus le cours
d'eau
en agriculture les bonnes riveraines
doivent atteindre au minimum trois
mètres à partir de la ligne des
hautes-aux cet espace qui n'est pas
cultivé est une sorte de bouclier qui
stabilise les rives et limite leur
ruissellement des engrais et des
pesticides ici les bandes riveraines
sont élargies à 8 mètres
un petit peu moins qu'un Hector en fait
qui est abandonné pour des bonnes
raisons d'énergie un peu moins d'un
hectare pour une terre qui en compte 220
de poser les protecteurs c'est Simon
côté qui gère la plantation il travaille
pour la Coopérative de solidarité arbres
évolution qui a lancé le programme
carbone on arrive à admettre tous les
morceaux ensemble pollinisation
ruissellement filtration
augmentation de la biodiversité il faut
comprendre que l'agriculteur lorsqu'on
fait une brise-vent ou qu'on élargit une
bonne riveraine c'est de la perte
d'espace cultivables donc c'est de la
perte de revenus pour lui il faut
absolument trouver une façon de
compenser financièrement cette perte-là
pour chaque hectare converti en bande
riveraine élargie les agriculteurs
reçoivent 22000 dollars la raison pour
laquelle on arrive à générer des sommes
d'argent pour compenser financièrement
l'agriculteur c'est à cause du marché du
marché volontaire du carbone dans le
cadre de ce marché des entreprises ou
des particuliers achètent volontairement
des crédits carbone pour compenser leurs
émissions de GES selon le programme
carbone riverain qui se base sur des
études faites dans le contexte québécois
chaque hectares de bandes riverain
élargies séquestrera un peu plus de 1500
tonnes de carbone sur 40 ans ici on a le
meilleur exemple c'est le papier hybride
lui c'est le champion séquestrateur
après 40 ans on peut s'imaginer à une
bille de bois relativement grande en
échange de la compensation financière
les agriculteurs doivent signer une
servitude à perpétuité ça veut dire que
plus jamais le producteur agricole
essaie descendants vont pouvoir cultiver
plus près de la rivière que ça même si
la terre est vendue ou cédé ou légué les
prochains propriétaires devront
respecter l'entente un peu comme on voit
avec Hydro-Québec lorsqu'un pilon
électrique est implanté dans un sur une
terre agricole ont des dommages
agriculteurs on signe une servitude puis
le sureau aussi qui va être ajouté là
sûrement demain ou après-demain pour
Guillaume faucher qui est aussi
agroéconomiste ce projet offre un bon
compromis entre protection de
l'environnement et rentabilité en tant
que je suis prêt à je vais protéger mes
cours d'eau c'est quand même bien public
je reconnais la valeur écologique de
tout ça mais un moment donné j'ai une
entreprise puis c'est mon gang pain puis
je peux pas assumer toutes les coups de
la protection de l'environnement pour
l'instant le prix des terres fait en
sorte qu'un programme de compensation
comme carbone riverain et plus
avantageux dans des régions où les
terres sont encore relativement
abordables la donne pourrait toutefois
changer car polluer coûtera de plus en
plus cher le prix de la tonne est voué à
augmenter ça pourra pas être moins que
22000 dollars hectares comme on donne
actuellement ça peut juste être plus
dans les prochaines années
les bandes riveraines ne sont pas
nouvelles on connaît leur bénéfice
depuis longtemps mais elles sont encore
trop peu respectées la citatif financier
sera peut-être la pièce qu'il manquait
pour qu'elle s'intègre de manière
durable dans le paysage agricole
ajoutez des arbres en bordure des champs
c'est une excellente façon de capter du
carbone mais ce n'est pas la seule le
sol sous nos pieds est un immense puit
de carbone sur lequel on mise de plus en
plus
en 2020 Kelly Garrett infirmier de
l'Iowa a fait la manchette
il a récolté plus de 340 mille dollars
américains en devenant l'un des premiers
agriculteurs à vendre des crédits
carbone l'un des acheteurs le géant du
magazine âge Shopify la plateforme
canadienne voulait s'afficher comme
étant carbon neutre et l'agriculteur a
profité du fait que ces bonnes pratiques
comme les engrais verts permettaient de
conserver du carbone dans le sol c'est
1200 hectares de terre continuent
d’ailleurs d’accumuler du carbone et lui
rapporte encore plus de 50000 dollars
par année mais le sol étant un peu comme
une éponge il y a une limite à ce qu'il
peut emmagasiner et le maximum sera
bientôt atteint c'est certain que il
faut être très très prudent c'est à dire
qu'on peut recommander comme ça des
grandes pratiques qu'on sait qui sont
généralement bénéfiques pour les sols
marie-hélice Samson une spécialiste des
sols de leur dire que on peut rétribuer
un agriculteur pour que une compagnie
puisse aller dépenser ce carbone là
ailleurs pour moi c'est sûr que je me
dis qu'il manque un peu de recherche il
faut qu'on développe encore nos
connaissances sur les seuls son domaine
d'études n'a jamais suscité autant
d'intérêt ça fait tout récemment un an
que je suis entré en poste comme
professeur et mon téléphone sonne sans
cesse que ce soit dans le gouvernement
qui veut mieux comprendre comment ça
fonctionne avant de prendre des
décisions que ça soit l'industrie aussi
qui va inviter dans la recherche par
rapport à la séquestration de carbone
dans les sols parce qu'ils sont
desireuses justement de d'avoir des
solutions pour acheter des tonnes et
carbone afin de pouvoir dire qu'ils sont
carbonade et donc oui on sent vraiment
un très très fort engouement au Québec
il n'existe pas encore de protocoles
reconnus pour que les agriculteurs
puissent tirer profit de réduction de
GES ou de quantité de carbone en
magasiné dans leur sol mais certains
travaillent à faire changer les choses
conseil en agronomie il accompagne les
agriculteurs dans leur transition
climatique
la seule ou qui non seulement peut
diminuer ses gaz à effet de serre mais
peu retirer du CO2 d'atmosphère mais
séquestré dans les sols sous forme de
matière organique c'est la photo
s'intègre comme technologie de retraite
CO2 tu peux pas avoir plus simple que ça
et plus petit que ça c'est aucune
technique à côté ça
aujourd'hui il
rencontre la vallée et sa fille Pascale
comment ça va oui
augmentation des taux de matière
organique dans le sol parce que chaque
fois qu'on retire par la photo synthèse
de CO2 ça ça a une valeur extraordinaire
dans le lieu qu'on des changements
climatiques mais si ça se monnaie c'est
un moment donné la valeur peut venir
être insecte pour nous
augmenter le taux de matière organique
c'est justement ce que tente de faire
les l'avaler dans ce champ de maïs
entre les rangs de maïs cette engrais
vert c'est ici du Trèfle du lin du radis
des plantes qui ne seront pas récoltées
mais qui vont apporter du carbone et
aussi de la vie dans le sol c'est un
changement total d'approche pour les
lavaler qui mènent aussi en parallèle
une transition vers l'agriculture
biologique il y a quelques années à
peine il se battait pour garder les
entre-temps bien propres tel qu'on les
voit encore dans la majorité des champs
de maïs de la province
[Musique]
là il y a quelque chose vraiment
extraordinaire là qui est en train de se
passer ils agriculteurs vont à la fois
s'adapter au changement climatique et
profiter d'un nouveau marché que jamais
existé avant la ferme des lavalie est
grande 1400 hectares réduire l'empreinte
carbone ici pour savérer payant pour
nous le projet de captation carbone ça
peut représenter plusieurs dizaines de
milliers de dollars par année donc ça
représente probablement le programme le
plus avantageux là qui aurait en fait
pour les agriculteurs et en plus il y a
des avantages à nous permettre
d'améliorer notre qualité de sol
d'améliorer notre matière organique dans
le sol en semant les engrais verts en
les enfouissant et en travaillant avec
la terre les matières organiques l'une
des clés pour amener du carbone dans le
sol c'est de le couvrir au maximum
de trèfle une coupe
de terrain de sol agricoles qui est pas
utilisé par une culture pour faire de la
photosynthèse tant que le climat il est
température le permet c'est cette
diversifie les cultures on en a
d'ailleurs un bel exemple dans ce champ
le blé vient tout juste d'être récolté
et on voit déjà une belle repousse de
trèfle une légumineuse entre les rangs
comme toutes les légumineuses c'est
l'équivalent d'une micro-usine d'engrais
azoté ces plantes arrivent à capter
l'azote de l'air et en faire un
fertilisant disponible pour la culture
suivante tout ça sans les émissions de
GES qui viennent normalement avec les
engrais chimiques on pratique pas
l'agriculture aujourd'hui comme on l'a
pratiqué il y a 10 ans je pense pas que
dans disait on va la pratiquer comme on
la pratique aujourd'hui mais la tendance
est quand même lourde pour prendre plus
conscience à l'environnement mais si les
veulent être rétribués pour le carbone
qu'il garde dans leur sol ça pose quand
même un défi car il faut mesurer ses
augmentations de matière organique cela
se fait avec des analyses de sol mais
pour avoir un portrait fidèle il en faut
beaucoup ce qui coûte cher non même si
le coup de l'analyse est très élevé
est-ce que ça peut être quand même
financièrement avantageux pour le
producteur ben ça ça va dépendre du prix
de la tomate donc le coût de l'atome de
carbone il faut pas que la mise en place
de cette comptabilité là soit tellement
dispendieuse que la valeur que ça a
enlève à l'agriculteur la valeur de ces
crédits compensatoires éventuels l'autre
enjeu c'est que les changements mis en
place par les agriculteurs devront être
permanents
dans des projets comme ça il faut que
s'engage sur le long terme sinon on peut
pas parler de séquestration de carbone
et donc ça veut dire que le producteur
ne peut pas décider qui rechange de
pratique plus tard sinon il y a des
chances pour que c'est un de carbone
dépensé par l'industrie finissent par
être émises quand même aussi par le sol
mais n'y a-t-il pas un danger déco
blanchiment que les bonnes pratiques des
agriculteurs servent en fait à des fins
de marketing pour verdir le blason de
certaines industries on peut pas juste
se dire on va continuer la vie comme
elle est et séquestrer du carbone dans
les sols et voilà la solution pas du
tout en fait il faut que la
séquestration de carbone dans les sols
soit vu pour tous ces coups bénéfices
aussi au niveau de l'agriculture la
durabilité de nos systèmes puis il faut
que ce soit vu comme un outil pour la
transition vers des énergies plus vertes
donc il va falloir de toute façon
réduire nos émissions réduire à la fois
nos émissions et tenter de renverser une
tendance
[Musique]
ça c'est c'est tout un défi c'est sûr
que ça sera pas facile
[Musique]